et puis une autre histoire d'îles
l'archipel des glénan dont on connaît la
fameuse école de voile des glénans le
lieu de villégiature des pirates au
xviie siècle est désormais le refuge de
centaines d'oiseaux une visite guidée
un rien nostalgique avec caroline halle
aux grains et jean-jacques le garrec
inutile de raconter à marcel chat feront
que l'ennemi sur le continent est plus
douce que dans les villes il ne vous
croirez pas je nomme la rochelle j'aime
la mer ce soir comme hbo
il connaît par coeur chaque caillou de
l'archipel il a vécu l'époque farc
une centaine de bateaux venus pêcher le
homard ou partout sur par fret le lock
ou saint nicolas il y avait des fermiers
les vaches et des doigts aujourd'hui
l'archipel n'est plus qu'une grande
réserve d'oiseaux
depuis quatre ans il aux moutons abrite
la dernière colonie de sternes du
finistère de jeu interactif favorables à
la reproduction des oiseaux marins on
les trouvait quantité d'espèces 3 et
nous faisons en sorte qu'elles se
reproduisent dans de bonnes conditions
et que leurs effectifs évidemment
s'améliorer au moment des plages digne
de la caraïbe que seuls les plaisanciers
ont le privilège d'accoster il y a
encore deux mois il de plein fouet
talent et son gardien de phare
mais comme tous ses collègues il a dû
regagner le continent
au début j'ai commencé de pétrole
ici c'est électrique tranché ici
les magnans sélectionné képi
et puis là
les pêcheurs du coin la place
saint-bernard desiles les jours de gros
temps il était le premier à appeler les
secours en cas de problème ils m'ont
surveillé et puis c'était là il ya une
présence humaine et en charme ya plus
personne alors surtout en bus était des
copains surtout ça
les îles se dépeuple cet hiver ils
seront quatre ou cinq pas plus à vivre
dans l'archipel juste assez pour faire
le soir une partie de cartes